avec moi laurent turcot professeur
d'histoire de verser du québec à trois
rivières
bonsoir monsieur du recours bonsoir moi
je parle de ça est vraiment je les dis
ce midi j'ai la chair de poule parce que
c'est peut-être un des meilleurs
exemples dans l'histoire ou deux hommes
seulement 2 en 2012 hommes de gaulle qui
fait cet appel là cette journée là le 18
juin et churchill qui ce jour là mais
quelques jours avant le mois de mai
avait fin ce discours célèbre ou du
jaune etc à vous offrir du sang des
larmes et de la douleur et bref sachant
ses deux jambes l'ont changé le cours de
l'histoire parce que tous les autres
beaucoup voulaient qu'on négocie avec
les zalman
ah oui il y en avait beaucoup qui
voulait négocier et vous avez raison de
mettre les deux ensemble parce que ces
deux orateurs mais d'une verve qu'on
connaît peu aujourd'hui quand on entend
les grands discours de nos politiciens
et de gaulle avait cette volonté de
croire en la france et il le dit dans
ses mémoires
je me fais une certaine idée de la
france mais cette idée de la france
l'appel du 18 juin il le symbolise par
le refus des conséquences dramatiques de
l'armistice parce que souvenons lula va
rappeler un peu le contexte pour les
gens qui sont un peu perdus début de la
deuxième guerre mondiale la france une
ligne maginot ont dit les allemands
passeront jamais par la vie passe par la
belgique
finalement et le 14 juin 1940 les
allemands donc les nazis défilent dans
paris le gouvernement se réfugie à
bordeaux et le 17 juin de gaulle donc
qui vient d'être nommé général est
mandaté pour aller à londres pour
discuter avec churchill
les deux hommes vont bien s'entendre il
va repartir le 18 juin
et là vous l'avez dit en ouverture le
gouvernement de philippe pétain le
maréchal pétain qui est un héros
militaire faut le rappeler aujourd'hui
c'est persona non grata personne ne veut
entendre parler pépin parce qu'il est le
symbole de celui que collaborer alors
que à l'époque de gaulle c'est lui qui
est persona non grata parce que quand il
fait son fameux appel du 18 juin
après ça le gouvernement de philippe
pétain vaut le considérer comme un
traître et la propagande var
loupé contre de gaulle mais ce fameux
appels qu'on a entendu l'ajustement
extraits vous l'avez dit également il ne
date pas du 18 juin du moins
l'enregistrement ou parce que la bbc le
perdu et surtout peu de gens l'ont
entendu malheureusement oui parce que à
l'époque et cherchell je le disais mais
expliquez moi le comte et cherchell par
chamberlain et puis à lui faxe avait des
pressions énormes pour négocier une paix
avec les allemands et de gaulle c'était
pas gagné d'avancé son pari d'où le
courage de cette c'était pas gagné
d'avant en fait les faits étaient plutôt
contre lui à l'époque ont complètement
quand on regarde l'histoire on sait où
ça s'en va on connaît la fin sauf qu'à
l'époque churchill fait face
est ce vous le voyez très bien dans le
film dark tower à la kiffe film
magnifique qui raconte justement cet
épisode avec winston churchill churchill
beaucoup d'opposants justement sa
politique qui veut confronter les nazis
de l'autre côté de gaulle est presque
inconnu aujourd'hui c'est ce grand
personnage de haute stature qui ont mis
en branle la vème république que l'on
connaît encore aujourd'hui en france
mais les deux hommes mais c'est un coup
de poker d'autant plus et ça c'est pour
les artistes voir le jour du 18 juin
churchill était occupée y avait pas le
temps de s'occuper que de gaulle donc de
gaulle reading son discours et le front
office de londres - d'angleterre regarde
le l'appel en question à 10 non c'est
pas possible on peut pas laisser passer
ça la bbc parce qu'on pense encore à
l'époque on peut négocier avec le
gouvernement de philippe pétain et c'est
à la dernière minute que winston
churchill arrive et dit niveau d'hier
grossièrement malo c'est fini c'est fini
les nièvre il vous laisser parler de
gaulle
il ya des choses fondamentales à dire et
l'ennemi c est clair point final
et l'on va commencer le grand
gouvernement en exil celui qu'on va
appeler de la france libre le de gaulle
vol incarner et dans son appel est
important il y en a beaucoup qui disent
il appelle les français à résister c'est
pas tout à fait ça c'est plus complexe
que ça ce qui va dire c'est qu'ils
avaient tous les militaires les
ingénieurs lee
sommes éventuellement les femmes qui
sont capables de l'aider de le rejoindre
à londres pour être capable avec
justement le gouvernement britannique de
s'opposer à la politique d'hitler
ça va prendre beaucoup de temps s'il va
commettre énormément de revers mais
heureusement 1944 voit arriver le
débarquement en normandie
et enfin comme il le dit pas paris sera
libéré parce que il dit dans son appel
puis vous avez raison c'est un appel à
venir le rejoindre pour redévelopper eu
des articles d'artillerie pour
développer des chats parce qu'ils on a
été battus par quoi par des chars par la
force technique d alma il faut donc avec
des ingénieurs des militaires retrouver
une technologie militaire de pointe et
on va revenir à la charge
on va revenir à la charge vous avez
raison mais il ya un aspect qu'on a
souvent laissé de côté et plus encore
dans tout le contexte mémorielle d'après
la deuxième guerre mondiale sekkaki de
gaulle s'adresse aussi pour reconstituer
son armée de la france libre bah son
empire colonial il va se servir de ces
colonies pour justement renforcer la
france la france ait perdu que ces
colonies lui vienne en aide
et là bien sûr si ce grand appel à la
patrie à la défense de la patrie est
l'incarnation d'un ennemi le mal parfait
qui étaient les nazis mais plus encore
faut rappeler parce qu'on dit deuxième
guerre mondiale
mais en fait il y en a eu trois gagne la
guerre franco-prussienne de 1870 la
première guerre mondiale et ensuite la
seconde
cette génération là aussi une génération
de guerre pourrait-on dire et plus
encore vous rajoutez part de sormano
beaucoup parler la grippe espagnole et
le crash de 29
disons que c'est de gaulle et toute sa
génération et s est ce gris generation
comment le qualifier mais quelques
heures plus tard est-ce que j'exagère
quand je dis le rang turcot ou tout
début parce que ça peut sembler
romantique là mais que le courage et la
détermination de deux hommes contre des
mouvements qui étaient contre est ce que
vraiment c'est pas bel exemple ou un ou
deux hommes
on peut faire la différence
quand on tousse on se lève même contre
un vent contre nous c'est vrai c'est
mais c'est toujours le problème est ce
que c'est les hommes qui font les
événements ou est ce que c'est les
événements qui font les hommes mais six
hommes leur faut qu'ils aient des gens
derrière eux je crois pauvres très
personnellement au fait que ce soit un
homme qui sont capables de tout mobilisé
d'un coup il incarne cette résistance il
n'est pas le seul
pour de gaulle on pourrait citer jean
moulin pour churchill
on pourrait citer des tonnes d'individus
dans le gouvernement qui était derrière
eux ils étaient la pointe de l'iceberg
mais vous avez raison de dire que c'est
des hommes qui avaient une capacité de
rassembler autour d'eux et on l'a vu par
la suite bas churchill a perdu les
élections à la fin de la guerre il va
revenir par la suite pour ceux qui ont
vu de chrome et de gaulle lui comme je
vous le disais tout à l'heure
ivo revenir et il va fonder la vème
république il ya vraiment un parallèle
et vous avez raison de le souligner et
j'invite justement les téléspectateurs à
les lire dans un premier temps les
mémoires de de gaulle
et pour ceux qui sont plus les films
high un film aussi sur de gaulle à voir
avec lambert wilson qui va sortir
bientôt ici et aussi bien sûr dort que
star wars
un film magnifique qui raconte ce
contexte de la guerre qu'on compte dont
on a une mauvaise préhension des fois et
on comprend pas à quel point le vent
aurait pu tourner d'un côté comme de
l'autre
c'est ce jeu vous dire avant d'avoir pu
tourner de l'autre bastille avait pas eu
là la force de caractère de churchill le
vent aurait pu très bien tourner vers
une compromission avec la les allemands
ont complètement puis d'autant plus que
l'angleterre se battaient seul à ce
moment là les américains n'étaient pas
entrés en guerre et le pacte
germano-soviétique tenait toujours
donc a priori l'allemagne gagné sur tous
les fronts la france était à genoux ça
allait mal l'angleterre n'est par la
bataille d'angleterre comme elle pouvait
les états unis avaient fait une entente
avec l'angleterre
c'est digne d'un film de hollywood où
est mort y en a eu l'assurance et des
[ __ ] de l'eau rentre dedans mais
gentiment le rang turcot le professeur
d'histoire de verser du québec à trois
rivières
c'est un plaisir de parler de tout ça
avec vous et
voilà puis j'espère que ça va intéresser
les gens les plus jeunes ou salés lire
l'histoire c'est quelque chose ce mois
de juin 1940 merci merci à vous au
revoir